my name is Kwame and this is Ken
Androids conceive of Electric Sheep
today I'm going to talk about a series
of experiments I tried to kind of
explore artistic expression
but first I'll tell you a little bit
about myself I've always kind of had a
fascination with creating and sharing
remember being a kid and staying up
until eight hours a night writing and
drawing stories when I got tired of
playing with my toys I actually used to
make my own toys out of household
objects that were so good that people
offered to buy them from me it was kind
of crazy when I was in middle school I
took up an interest in trying to make
video games so I took a C++ course and
really fell in love with programming
it's a really an unparalleled way to
create and share which is really
important to me and really programming
is kind of a superpower right especially
these days so you share the right thing
and all of a sudden everyone in the
world sees it so I've been obsessed
pretty much ever since so I've worked on
a lot of different types of software
since I wrote my first line of code
including instant messaging and social
networking but ultimately really the
same things motivate me as they did when
I wrote my first line of code I'm really
all about exploring the margins of
knowledge and trying out new ideas and
really just asking what if and that's
really what this talk is about
I asked what if and we'll see if I asked
what if too many times by the end of the
talk so several years ago I was working
on a photo sharing app and you know I
had an idea what if we create a secret
URL where people could go and see their
photos appearing before their eyes and I
didn't know exactly what that meant but
in my mind it maybe was a sketch or some
sort of painting or something like that
you know I thought it would I thought
it'd be really fun for people all right
unfortunately that company was against
Easter eggs but the idea really stuck
with me for a while so surely after I
conceived of this idea was that a
weekend hackathon decided to give the
idea try had the rough idea in my head
had kind of been bouncing around I
figured try edge detection consider the
pixels sort of a graph of connected
nodes and do a depth-first search really
had no idea what I was doing but
downloaded open CV fired up them and
couple hours later I had a really rough
working prototype there we go okay so
the first version wasn't exactly what I
envisioned but
decently well you got a sense of some
hidden form slowly revealing itself
which is kind of what I was after but
the pixels being drawn just seemed kind
of random and it really just almost
feels like a printer kind of doing its
thing right so of course the next
natural step was to slow down the
drawing speed a little bit at a hand
maybe add pauses between the paths and
it's looking a little bit better
movement isn't totally smooth but it
still feels pretty awkward right drawing
kind of starts in the bottom-right
corner it's moving kind of randomly I
think we can do a little bit better so I
start to think carefully like what what
does it look like when I draw or when
someone else draws and I tried out
introducing a notion of section ordering
and path ordering and that makes sense
right because you're drawing a an image
or painting a picture you kind of start
in one section and if you start with the
longest paths it's almost like you're
drawing an outline and then the shorter
paths are the details so all of these
were just kind of rough proxies for the
actual creative process but I think it
got me pretty far so there is one more
kind of nagging thing with this
particular version as the hand moves in
between paths and I don't know if anyone
else is picking up on that but it does
feel kind of awkward because when you're
moving your hand you don't really keep
it close to a canvas right you kind of
pick it up and put it back down and so
that was the last thing I added and this
is way overkill for a JavaScript
prototype but it was a lot of fun to
work on so something kind of funny
happened when I got to this point so
this version of the hack actually far
exceeded my original expectations but
feels kind of human-like but not not
quite right so all of a sudden I just
felt deeply dissatisfied with what I had
done even though it exceeded my
expectations it kind of reminds you of
thing from Adams family I don't know if
anyone remembers that so I didn't
realize it at the time but this was the
beginning of a descent into the uncanny
valley so there's a quick refresher the
uncanny valley happens when you have a
figure or some stimulus that feels
almost human but not quite and it evokes
that really eerie feeling and there are
lots of theories for why that is
but it's no trivial matter when you're
working on a humanoid characters you
want to consciously avoid this uncanny
valley you either want to be extremely
human or not lifelike at all or else you
risk kind of falling into this so when
this goes wrong the results are results
oh pretty horrifying pretty horrifying
let's go to the next slide so of course
my hack is it nearly as bad as that last
slide but there is something a little
uncanny about watching this disembodied
hand just zip around the screen right
and I think most people when they have
that sort of uncanny valley experience
are inclined to head in the other
direction but I think it's technologists
we sort of see it as a call to action
right we're drawn to two hard problems
two interesting problems so I just had
this urge to make this thing feel more
human-like what can I do here what would
take to climb out of this valley so
reflecting on it I figured the
challenges kind of fall into two buckets
so the first is human cognition right
how do people think about the process of
drawing and the second is human
biomechanics mechanically what are they
doing how are they moving answering
those questions would be vital if I
wanted to make my way out of this valley
so around a year later I started working
on really small iOS game and the basic
premise was that you watch an image
being drawn and you try to guess what's
being drawn as quickly as possible and
the faster you guessed the more points
you get so I figured this would be a
cool way to turn that little crappy
weekend hack into something a little bit
more and at first my interest was
primarily in designing a really engaging
game experience but as you can probably
predict I start to fall into that
uncanny valley again so the prototype of
the hand was a pretty good start but as
we already saw watching a disembodied
hand draw photos it's just a little bit
weird maybe even a little bit creepy so
what I need here is probably just a
whole arm so how do you implement
something like that what if you model it
as a chain of joints so we already have
this stream of pixels right and that
gives us the position of the hand over
time so if you have the position of the
hand maybe you can work backwards and
figure out the rest of the arm so I
started with this prototype just to
refine the math and validate
sumption x' and the math behind our
movements is pretty straightforward
right so you have four known values you
have your shoulder position you have
your hand position you have the length
of your humerus and the length of your
ulna and radius right so we essentially
want to figure out the position of the
elbow and that's gonna move the further
away our hand gets from our body and you
can think of the length from your
shoulder to your hand
as sort of this third side of a triangle
that includes the other parts of your
arm right if we know all three sides of
a triangle it's pretty easy to figure
the rest out using the law of cosines so
I won't spend too much time on this but
breaking it down to geometric terms work
works really well because it's a really
concise way to encode the constraints we
experience in the physical world and
this was a really important lesson for
me so coding this was a lot of fun and
seeing the working prototype come to
life was pretty motivating I'll show you
that in a second but first what I didn't
realize is that all I was doing was
actually recreating a really well-known
process in computer animation and
robotics it's called rigging and inverse
kinematics so rigging is the process of
taking a model it could be a human it
could be an animal could be a robot but
taking a model and designing an
interconnected skeleton so that you can
easily pose it in many different poses
without without having to animate the
whole thing all over again and then
inverse kind of inverse kinematics is
about basically moving in into actuator
which is just a fancy robotics term for
hand so you move your hand around and
that basically helps you orient the rest
of your body so that's that's a much
more formal definition of everything I
just described
so both rigging and inverse kinematics
are absolutely foundational to the area
computer animation I K is a really
efficient way to code a lot of these
complex animations I'll talk more about
that in a second but it's also a really
important piece to the uncanny valley
puzzle there's actually an entire
ecosystem of software built around
helping engineers put AI K into
realistic character animations so here's
what my inverse kinematics
implementation looks like on iOS this
was undoubtedly a leap full
from the disembodied hand approach right
and seeing an arm attached does feel
pretty cool but the animation still
doesn't feel quite lifelike I'll give
you a second to watch this and this is a
sculpture being drawn the thinker but
also watching that arm move around just
feels kind of weird I mean part of it is
a little bit of animation jank but it
were still maybe sliding back into the
uncanny valley so at this point I had a
long backlog of really small tweaks to
implement to make this feel satisfactory
and each one represented such a small
step out of that valley that I became a
little bit less bullish on this idea and
I really concluded that making this feel
satisfactory would would probably
require 3d rendering or something a
little bit more advanced than what I'm
doing here so before moving on to the
next section I want to want to take a
quick detour to kind of set the stage
for us to talk so I'll tell you what
happened next in a moment but before
doing that we really have to talk about
bob ross so bob ross is best known for
his show of the joy of painting ran for
31 seasons over 11 years ended in 1994
and this show Bob teaches you to paint
primarily using the wet-on-wet technique
which is a really forgiving technique so
beginners can create things pretty
easily that they're pretty proud of so
if you've ever seen bob ross you know
he's known for his calming smooth
demeanor bob passed away in 1995 at age
52 and for context there were only 16
million users on the internet this was
three years before Google was founded
when he died and ten years before go
YouTube was founded and yet he has tons
of memes floating around a series on
Netflix in over three million
subscribers on YouTube that's how much
of a badass Bob Ross was but I digress
Bob Ross deserves a shout-out today
because he taught millions of people the
joy of creative expression he taught us
to use our imaginations to savor the
moment and to enjoy life's happy
accidents watching him paint was a
little bit like watching a magician you
watch the scene come to life and it just
seems like he's just effortlessly
flicking his brush around just humming
to himself it's kind of incredible
he does this in less than 25 minutes I
mean think about that can you even cook
dinner in less than 25 minutes can you
finish a meeting in less than 25 minutes
I think not
imagine Bob Ross outside painting this
before you finish your meeting so the
other thing he taught us was that it is
kind of enjoyable that watched this
creative process play out I mean he
starts to this blank canvas and he's
just living in a zone of genius even
when you're not an active participant
this is a really special thing to be a
part of so as we continue to talk about
emulating the cognition and biomechanics
of an artist's or kind of talking about
creating a virtual bob ross so as I
begin to think about making a 3d version
of this program I learned a lot about
the world of 3d animation including
rigging which I mentioned inverse
kinematics motion capture a bunch of 3d
game engines and much more and I began
to saw a little bit of light at the end
of the tunnel or at the top of the
valley and I began to imagine how this
would work the disembodied hand approach
feels really weird so what a disembodied
arm approach feeling different I think
disembodiment might be the uncanny thing
here right I concluded that the right
next step was probably incorporating a
full-on 3d model so this point had a
good idea of how to architect that I'd
done the web version I'd done the iOS
version after a little research I chose
a 3d game engine called unity so there's
an abundance of resources and free
assets available and it's pretty easy to
set up a basic scene but 3d models have
no inherent notion of movement so
they're inherently lifeless and
inherently uncanny so how can we fix
that let's talk about how animations
generally work so the way to achieve
complex movement and games or movies
it's actually not to create hundreds of
nuanced animations what people generally
do is combine relatively simple
animations and complex sequences and
apply them to different body parts using
different weights using different
timings they basically build up these
complex recipes to give you the behavior
you're looking for its kind
like cooking so bloody animation is
really a big part of how all these
dynamic characters that were all
accustomed to come to life in this
example is relatively simple there are
just two animations there's running and
jumping what's actually happening is as
the character begins to jump that run
animation is phased out and when they
land it's faced back in and ten years
ago or probably 15 years ago this wasn't
that common so 15 years ago this would
have been magic today we just take it
for granted but there's a lot of
sophisticated math actually going in the
background and interpolation between
different animations and they're just
two animations here but you could in
theory have dozens or maybe hundreds of
animations in some cases so as a result
of this sort of blending behavior we get
nice smooth and natural maybe not
lifelike in this case but very natural
feeling movement so what kind of recipe
should we be using for artists let's
talk about that so here's what the scene
looks like before the model has any
notion of animation so you can see a
pencil sort of flying around the screen
right now otherwise the scene is pretty
basic the only thing that I implemented
kind of is the the drawing speed is
modulated so that at the beginning of
the path it's slow at the end of the
path it's slow so it's kind of mimics
that sort of natural drawing movement
right so what should this sort of
animation recipe for artists look like
so the first thing I added was an idle
animation and this seems really mundane
perhaps but this is actually super
important so the idle animation
basically gives every single limb in
fiber of this characters being something
to do when I haven't told it what to do
which is essentially what we're all
doing right so this is kind of the base
layer of this recipe so next thing we
want to do is animate the arm in hand we
already talked about inverse kinematics
quite a bit I mentioned there's already
this rich ecosystem it was a checkbox in
a one-liner which is really awesome but
here's what it looks like so this is
just yeah so this is just the weird
nuance where the hand is defined as the
wrist in the standard model so we add in
another layer where we tweak
both the hand position in the rotation
to sort of simulate what it's like to
grab a pencil at different angles right
kind of tweaking the torquing the wrist
a little bit as you reach out at
different angles so this looks much
better but you looks much better but you
might notice that the fingers are kind
of idling still right I don't know if
anyone can see that in the back but we
want to do is kind of just curl the
fingers to simulate pinching a pencil
all right
so it took four ingredients just for
that arm in hand to look somewhere
realistic so those look pretty good at
this point but what about the rest of
the body I don't know if you picked up
on this but as this arm is moving around
the characters face is just sort of
staring ahead like this right because
that's just what it does by default but
then also the torso isn't adjusting so
when the character goes far the left
it's kind of at this unnatural angle
right so these are pretty easy tweaks
right so we simply modulate the angle of
the head to direct its gaze at the at
the pencil and that already makes a
pretty huge difference in how natural
animation feels unless you happen to be
looking at the shoulders so what do we
do about that torso so really we want to
rotate the hips for it to account for
two cases we're going left or going left
to right when the cursor is going left
or right we want to turn when the
crystal is going up and down when it
bent back slightly and then forward
great so this is yet another layer to
add but fairly easy to add right so once
we add that in then this is looking
pretty good this is looking pretty good
and when you see it side by side with
that first sort of zombie-like version
the effect is even more pronounced so
there were more tweaks in this and this
was a pretty long process but it's kind
of fun to iterate on every time you add
something then makes a huge difference
it feels a little bit more lifelike and
we can keep tweaking this indefinitely
but I'm gonna stop here and move on to
another challenge I encountered so the
next thing I want to talk about is path
ordering so I know this the order that
paths are painted felt subtly unnatural
so consider this figure how would you
reproduce this if you had
paint for example or some other some
other material where you could just
paint over or draw over other layers
well for most of this image is pretty
straightforward but for the overlapping
portion it is a little bit tricky a
person would probably start with a blue
circle but by default the computer just
sees a blue Crescent right now this
isn't the most natural shape to draw
it's not impossible for an experienced
artist but if you don't have to why
would you right path of least resistance
people intuitively understand that if
materials allow they actually have a
pretty big margin of error because
they're gonna paint over certain regions
of the image later so when we have these
overlapping objects we don't actually
have to get things 100% right and it
does feel a little bit weird when you
have a really complex image and you have
your sort of virtual artists drawing
these intricate paths that just don't
matter in the grand scheme of things you
know how can we make this feel a little
bit more like human cognition I think a
human artist would probably do something
like this where maybe I need to get that
left side really accurate but the right
side is just the blob who cares I'm
gonna have a green circle right and
green circle it looks perfect so how can
we turn that Crescent into a shape that
feels more natural for a person to draw
so it turns out this required another
implementation of that path generate
about the depth first search wasn't
really cutting it and here's why so
what's happening is that as I mentioned
all that's this computer sees and with
you that first search is this Crescent
which isn't that useful right it doesn't
understand how it relates to other
pixels in the image so I used an open CV
function called find contours an open CV
a contour is really just a line the
collection of points and sometimes those
points close to form a nice shape and
sometimes they're just an open curve but
either way they're treated the same way
an open CV and you can do some nice
things with drawing but they're treated
the exact same way
so the really nice thing about fine
contours is that it gives us a contour
hierarchy and once you have the
hierarchy you can start to make
inferences about the image topology
other words you understand a little bit
about how those pixels are related to
each other
so in this slide you can see two types
of sub graphs illustrates the two types
of overlap so we have the partial
overlap right and that's on the left
side and then we have the complete
overlap on the right side or rather one
contour completely within another so the
contour hierarchies for any image will
contain dozens or hundreds of these sub
graphs in addition to other types of
structures and you'll notice in the
second case that those actually look
pretty natural so we're gonna focus on
that at left side for now so the next
calculation is what I call coming up
with a natural contour for the image so
there are two steps here so we want to
calculate what's called the convex hull
for that contour so the convex hull is
the smallest convex shape that contains
the entire contour right so if you don't
remember that remember that this is
basically a nice way to fudge all the
parts of the image that are difficult to
draw right because that smallest convex
shape is basically just gonna draw
straight lines over any of the concave
portions and the concave portions are
the ones that are gonna typically cause
us trouble especially when they're part
of these interlocking images right so we
calculate that convex hull and then we
make sure that convex hull doesn't
overlap with the visible parts of any
other contours that are drawn earlier if
it overlaps with things that are drawn
later that's fine because gets painted
over but we want to make sure it doesn't
overlap with things that are drawn
earlier and here's sort of the net
result here and this is a really simple
example but on the left you can see that
original approach right which doesn't
feel that natural on the right we have
something that more closely approximates
what an actual artist would do so I
started thinking about this because at
some point I'd love to port all this
code to a robotic arm and if I do all
that work and it looks like the left
side I'm gonna be real upset so that's
what I started thinking about it and
this is a obviously a stylized image on
the right just so you can see sort of
the olla overlap so moving on to another
challenge next I want to talk about
image segmentation and this is this is
really challenging it's a very active
area of research so far I've been using
simple edge detection to extract paths
from the image that approach actually
isn't that great
if you've ever tried edge detection on
an image then you know that you spend a
lot of time fine-tuning parameters and
then you still encounter plenty of edge
cases where it just doesn't work so the
big problem is that for some lighting
conditions you just get too many or too
few edges but then also if you have an
object in the foreground that's even
somewhat similar to the background they
just kind of go on together right so
when objects are drawn sometimes we draw
several objects at once rather than
completing one object and then moving on
to the other one which just feels kind
of weird we still have sort of that
printer effect and even if this isn't
using the section or path or ting I
described but even if it did it would
feel pretty random beyond that though it
might be pretty useful later on to know
what objects are in the scene so what we
want to do is segment the scene based on
the objects it contains so so far we've
been using pixel based image
segmentation and there are lots of
different algorithms you can use but
they all work basically the same way you
reduce the number of colors in the image
and you examine adjacent pixels and
group the ones together if they have
similar color values so most versions of
this are simple and fast but just not
very accurate what we want is actually
fairly advanced right so it's not enough
to know that the image contains a person
because we want to know where the person
is right it's also not enough to know
whether a pixel belongs to a person
because if there are multiple people in
the image we actually want a different
object for each person and this is
called instant segmentation that's what
we actually want of course this is
something we can all do effortlessly
right because most of us can do it this
effortlessly because we have advanced
visual systems in fact it's kind of
remarkable if you see something you
don't recognize like if you look around
the room you probably won't see them
more than like one or two things that
you don't recognize so in the best case
this technique allows us to assign every
single pixel to an object exactly what
we want but this is a very active area
of research and even state-of-the-art
techniques aren't that great yet but of
course this is the technology that
enables really advanced computer vision
use cases like autonomous vehicles very
active area of research so in order to
make this work at
and yet another path generator but I was
relying a lot on Facebook
ai researches mask or CNN so this time
the past generator is responsible for
identifying those objects but then it
hands it off to the contour path
generator we get contours for the object
individually and then we also well
actually I'll talk about the next path
generator a moment so we're still
reusing a lot of the same logic
so using this instant segmentation
technique allows us to produce a much
more realistic emulation of the artistic
process you can see in this example that
discernible objects are being rendered
even though there's a lot of overlap
right with the foreground in the
background after adding instant
segmentation I was pretty happy with
this artists ability to recreate scenes
in a way that felt pretty similar to an
artist thought process at least
mechanically but there was one more
thing that was kind of nagging me about
this artists and that's that it was just
for GERD stating bites on my hard drive
that's just kind of boring there were
some abstract forms being abstracted but
those are just mistakes right I was
curious if I could take this a step
further is it possible to introduce some
notion of creativity I generally didn't
know so I looked to the world of
generative art for some inspiration so
in case you're not familiar he's a
frequently cited definition art
programmed using a computer that
intentionally introduces randomness as
part of its creation process that sounds
like the right direction okay so here's
a really early example from 1968 you can
see how the square start out uniform at
the top and then towards the bottom the
position and rotation of those squares
is just modulated randomly increasingly
randomly as we approach the bottom this
is super interesting I love how it sort
of illustrates order and chaos on the
same image I really like this piece I
might even get a print of it but I'm not
sure it's the type of creativity I have
in mind here's a more recent example
from Tyler Hobbs this is this from 2017
so this is the output of a program that
actually simulates watercolor paint
which is really cool so I'm impressed by
this piece for many reasons my favorite
thing is that
just created bytecode it's really cool
but I'm not sure this is the type of
creativity I have in mind so here's a
screenshot from something called deeply
artificial trees which it's a short film
um so this was the result of a neural
network getting its hands on the joy of
painting so that's that used to be Bob
Ross so I'm really just scratching the
surface here obviously there are tons of
examples of general art from the past
several decades but I didn't find it was
very many examples of what I was looking
for what I realized I was looking for
some sort of higher-level creativity
neural network art comes close right but
it's not not really about human right I
have a hard time believing a person came
up with this and if they did have a hard
time believing they chose to share it so
emulating creativity is complex but
creativity itself seems pretty
straightforward I mean so I thought is
it creativity just taking ideas and
synthesizing new ones approximating
human level creativity totally
intractable giving AI the ability to you
know develop taste and have the same
sort of aesthetic values as person
probably a pipe dream but I wanted to
see how far I could get anyway so there
are lots of ways to think about
creativity but I really like this quote
creativity is just connecting things
when you ask creative people how they
did something they feel a little guilty
because they didn't really do it they
just saw something it seemed obvious to
them after a while so I like this quote
perhaps creativity is just about making
connections between things you kind of
already know I think I think there's
something to that
so one of common way to encode knowledge
is as a set of objects and relationships
between those objects and these are
sometimes referred to as as concept
grabs and knowledge graphs I believe
that creativity can largely be described
as a set of operations on concept
graphed so for example finding an
analogy is a matter of finding two sets
of notes with a similar relational
structure and I'm gonna illustrate that
and those structures can be simple or
complex that's just one example but just
intuitively I feel like creativity can
be broken down that way so let's see
what happens so green is the color as
orchid is to flower I assume most people
understand why that's an analogy this is
a pretty easy example node a is a type
of node B so the next one seems easy but
humanist of fingernail is Tigers to claw
so I think intuitively most of us feel
like these two things are analogous but
can you explain why they're analogous I
think that's much more difficult if we
can't explain why we're gonna have
trouble implementing it so here was my
attempt to explain it in words node a
has a multi fingered appendage comprised
in part by node B that's actually kind
of an inadequate description it kind of
gets at the heart of the matter but it's
kind of interesting that it's difficult
to articulate and yet I think most or
all of us in this room would say in an
instant yes they those two things are
analogous so given that we talked about
talked about with concept graphs how
might we emulate creativity so what if
we met operations on the concept graph
like the one I just described its
operations on an image so I'm going to
give you just one example so if we're
given objects what if we replace the
background image but the location where
you typically find that object so the
operation is start with the objects and
find a typical location and then the
transform that we're matching is replace
background with that location so what
would happen in this simple example and
this is a manual example but what would
happen here so this is a chicken on a
plate so at first glance maybe this
seems a little bit random or it seems
like someone has a sick sense of humor
it's definitely whimsical but it also
kind of makes sense it elevates this
narrative that most people think of
chickens just as food I actually found
this relationship in a real concept
graph though and in addition to plate
the other locations include pizza
freezer and oven so not sure we would
have done much better here
so we just talked about two simple
transforms and we can define as many as
a 1 and chaining these together gives us
ever more complex images so here's my
proposed creativity algorithm so you can
start with a seed image you can do
instant segmentation to extract objects
you can run all permutations of
available transforms on the recognized
objects themselves and then you can
choose the ones with the highest score
to simulate some notion of taste and I'm
going to talk about where we get the
score from in a second but why don't we
try that so here's how I try to
implement that so I mentioned previously
that I'm using masks are CNN and this is
actually trained on a data set called
cocoa common objects in contexts so
basically my artist is able to recognize
80 different objects which isn't very
many so next I cross-referenced those
recognized objects with concept net
which is an open concept graph and that
gives us some of what I was just talking
about where we have this active concept
graph that's actually maintained we can
try to run operations on it we can see
what happens so a quick note about
scoring concept net for each objects or
sorry for each edge includes a weight so
for example between chicken and plate
there's a weight so for scoring I can
compare something like chicken on a
plate to something like chicken on a
pizza I can come up with which one is
better
so from my proof of concept here the
transforms I decide to implement so
implemented if all objects share our
location replace the background if two
objects have an analogy with two other
cocoa objects remove the objects in the
image and insert the cocoa objects if
there's a round object like a tennis
ball replace it with a random round
object in cocoa and then finally if two
objects sharing is a relation meaning
them of the same type isolate objects by
removing all the objects so not two dogs
but more like two mammals and for that
last one in case it's not obvious there
are two reasons that's there so one is
that focusing people's attention is a
form of creativity you're kind of
choosing which part of the image to
elevate but the other thing is
it also enables more interesting
transforms later in the pipeline so for
example in one permutation we have in is
a transform first and then in isolates
objects then when we run the first the
first transform where we where when all
objects have the same location would
replace the background then that
transform is going to find common
objects much more frequently after that
sort of isolation transformers run and
of course maybe that will get thrown out
but it's worth evaluating so we can
compare it against thousands of other
permutations okay so let's let's see how
well this works so in this example we
have a carousel we have a bunch of
animals on that carousel we have some
people in the background there's a lot
going on this scene this is a little
this is a little bit of visual cacophony
Tuffy before a person a parse so what do
you think we'll get so in this case
might be our kind of hard to see in the
projector at the elephant the horse were
actually pulled out of the original
scene and render it in front of a tent
from a circus
so it's sort of an interpreted this
elephant and horses live elephant horse
by that I mean that's to be expected it
doesn't you can't tell the difference
between a fake horse and a real one but
this is actually a good illustration of
that isolation transform I mentioned
that play because that wouldn't have
happened because there are people that
wouldn't have happened unless we just
pulled out the animals and explored what
we can do with them so in this next
example this is a photo of a hand model
or something wearing a watch so what do
you think will happen here
so in case you can't see that the artist
decided to replace the face of the
wristwatch with a stop sign it's
actually recognizing the watch face as a
clock in this case that's one of the
koko optics and replacing it with a
random round object but this God works
it kind of works this could be like a
visual pun it could be stopwatch or it
could be sort of couldn't have some
higher meaning it could be reminding us
to stay present and not care so much
about the time but I really like this
one so there are a lot of failure faces
as you can guess so this is a cat and a
bird and let's see what happens here so
you probably can't tell what's going on
there um it took me a second to so
there's a baseball player in the middle
and there's a dog in the top right and
so what I notice is that the analogy is
produced by this data set are usually
pretty strange we're only able to
recognize 80 objects as I mentioned and
also the relationships in the concept
graph just aren't that precise and I
think that's more a weakness of natural
language processing in general than
concept met but obviously the desire
cats have for birds is very different
from the desire people have for dogs and
this just doesn't make that much sense
and let's move on so in this last
example we have someone delivering a
forearm to a tennis ball so what what do
you think is gonna happen here and that
is a that is a tennis doughnut so this
this was probably the first image I saw
when I got object replacement working
and it made me laugh out loud it was an
awesome experience okay so just like
other forms of generative art this
creativity isn't nearly 100% on in
autonomous since I'm choosing the
versions I like best I generally don't
know what I'm gonna see though when I
run this script but I'm often amused and
each creation is sort of like a visual
puzzle or riddle and I'm also sort of
retrofitting meaning onto the images
after seeing them right this I did
program this to spit out titles but
they're kind of
nonsensical at this point but you know I
think this is kind of similar to what we
do right so we Traverse our sort of
internal concept graph we find
interesting structures then we retrofit
meaning based on how we see ourselves
how we see the world right there is no
inherent meaning in destruction our
knowledge it's all about the context
that we add so I don't know I I kind of
feel like it's somewhat faithfully
recreates the creative process so this
this started is a really tiny hack mount
project but as you can see it turned
into something much more I never never
thought I'd take this this tiny crazy
idea this far I learned a ton working on
this gained a much much greater
appreciation for it but a big thing I
realize is that iterating on software
really is a lot like iterating on your
drawing or painting with each
incremental improvement starts to take a
little bit more shape a little bit more
shape so I was a lot more work to do
before we see this stuff auction off at
Sotheby's or this artist has a huge
Instagram cult following you know I see
those challenges as a call to action I'm
gonna keep plugging away at it so I just
before I go to questions I wanted to
call out all the technologies I use for
this just open CV which is open source
GPU image open source NASCAR CNN is a
technique devised by a facebook a a
research I'm using matter ports
implementation of masks or our CNN I
think it's like a actually not sure it
matter for this unity concept net open
concept graph you should check that out
and then finally cocoa which is
maintained by Facebook Microsoft a lot
of big companies and really is is really
important to computer vision research so
with that I think I might have time for
one or two questions if Heaven right
here
that's a fantastic question so I think I
need to automate myself I I did mention
that I don't think that I you know I
said something like I think giving a
computer any sort of notion of
aesthetics is a pipe dream but the
problem here is that there are so many
combinations created that it is hard to
find the really good ones and this is
actually a really simple version of the
program where each transform is only
applied once and they're only four
transforms and they're very basic but
suppose you had ten some of them are
more advanced so for example you see an
umbrella and you make other objects rain
that's something I've been working on
you all of a sudden you know the the
complexity explodes every time you add a
transform and actually as you can
imagine once I got to for all of a
sudden this thing was taking seconds to
run and as you would expect but yeah I
think it's I think it's a matter of sort
of automating myself but to actually
answer your question I don't think it'll
ever be done
[Music]
I didn't consider that one thing I have
considered though is incorporating some
notion of scene understanding which is
somewhat similar what you're saying but
not exactly so you guys aren't familiar
there's another very active area of
research where we're training AI to
basically look at a photo and extract
you know full sentences and really
extract you know full concepts so that
that's as far as I thought about it but
it almost sounds like you're talking
about like seeding with a word instead
of an image right I hadn't thought about
that but I'm gonna try it that's a great
question I mean I think I had the first
idea like four years ago I implemented
the first version two years ago and then
yeah from there I was exploring some
business ideas the iOS game was a
business idea some of it was implemented
specifically for the talk I saw this as
a really good opportunity to try out a
lot of these more ambitious ideas about
creativity so that was kind of a
timeline but as far as fine at the time
I mean it's it's a matter of like
closing reddit in hacker news literally
that's probably time it's the next
speaker thank you